When people speak, often they'll use what's called filler words such as "ums" and "ahs".
They'll finish one sentence and say "um", then go on to the next one.
Now, this is a habit that you can break with a bit of practice.
I personally still say "ums" and "ahs" occasionally.
Let me tell you right now, I'm nowhere near perfect.
A good way to cure yourself from saying "ums" and "ahs"...
...is that once you say a sentence, you pause, closing your mouth,...
...then go on to the next one.
Remember, it's okay to pause when you speak.
In fact, pausing is a very effective way to give a speech...
...because it gives the audience time to think of what you've just said...
...rather than saying "um" or "ah" in between.
Now, this will take a bit of practice.
But after time, you'll find that the number of "ums" and "ahs" you say will be a lot, lot less.